stay on it stay on it whoa - it's common
all right we're doing it stream they all
may oh my god this is gonna be so silly
yeah all right oh that is smart
but then if there's a spare skirt right
anyone who can basically jump over it
also at all would only box people out
for like four seconds oh it's a massacre
it's a massacre you wouldn't you there's
with do more damage we just gotta get to
the thing just hurl more maze at the
snowball progress this is going okay
this is the best or nice icicle
it doesn't matter ice everyone's death
yes yes yes yes right chapter point
number one now for capture point B how
are you gone
nice try that's why you don't run away
wiener punching the old buttocks the old
boot arewe we climb this you can a hole
what a shot crimson jackass
just seeing different characters battle
it out I'll come join you okay oh here
you go
nice my eyes oh we need we need
shield-wall throws use one oh there was
no escape
alright this could be it this could be
good this looks really good
save your ice ball oh I just got pushed
out by my own teammate that's okay
stay on it
stay on it oh I saw its comin we're
doing it you're doing it dude oh no
don't ruin the moment you ruined the
moment you stupid ass yeah hey Mei Mei
we did it whoo hey we got one
non-matching may you get out of here
dude yeah hey may all your animations
there at ya right here
is that hot triple
we get that other guy to that jerk that
comes later but we'll take it so good
yeah what a game not a way to get me
you